«SoftServe» — це українська ІТ-компанія,
за останніми даними — це 12 тисяч людей.
Це таке невеличке місто.
Ми, як ніхто, відчуваємо свою
відповідальність перед країною,
де ми живемо, перед містами,
у яких ми живемо.
Коли ти маєш можливість
зробити якісь класні речі,
які ніхто інший у цьому суспільстві не робить,
неправильно цього не робити.
«SoftServe» займався соціальними
активностями із самого початку створення.
Просто більше 20 років тому
не було такого модного тренду.
Це просто йшло в рамках: потрібно
допомогти нашим працівникам чимось,
чи потрібно допомогти університету,
чи потрібно допомогти школам, медичним закладам.
І ми цим займалися постійно,
просто в якийсь момент зрозуміли,
що ця робота потребує кращої організації,
більш систематичного підходу,
і так 2014 року ми створили
наш благодійний фонд «Відкриті очі».
Це єдиний благодійний фонд
при IT-компанії в Україні,
який функціонує окремо як юридична особа.
У нас є кілька категорій проєктів.
Медицина, освіта, військові — такі наші основні
три кити, на яких тримається фонд.
Особливість у тому, що будь-яка ідея,
яка вже потім втілюється як проєкт,
вона йде від працівника компанії.
Ми побачили, що люди готові,
вони вже в силі, в стані
і мають велике бажання творити
щось цікаве та соціально потрібне.
Якісь важливі речі, які когось турбують,
а ми як IT-компанія маємо потужний ресурс,
щоб це в той чи інший спосіб вирішити.
Клієнти з-за кордону звертають увагу
на корпоративно соціальну відповідальність,
яка вона є: чи це просто на словах,
чи справді відбуваються якісь дії,
чи це імплементовано,
чи це лише просто заявка про те,
які ми класні і добрі.
У суспільстві дедалі більше є запит
працівників чи потенційних
працівників при виборі компаній,
вони, зокрема, керуються тим,
чи є ця компанія соціально відповідальна,
знову ж таки, тому що вони хочуть,
щоб їхня праця на компанію
приносила користь не тільки їм,
не тільки компанії,
але й середовищу, у якому вони живуть.
Спершу ми запускали таку анкету
на співробітників з питанням:
«Чи ви потенційного готові
були б поволонтерити? У яких напрямах?»
Ми дістали дуже багато позитивних відповідей.
І зрозуміли, що є якийсь ресурс,
з яким можна працювати
і з яким хочеться працювати.
А, як показує практика,
на цих волонтерських проєктах
збираються люди близькі за духом,
і вони зрештою затримуються на них.
Тому що їм цікаво бути разом,
спілкування, якісь заходи і так далі.
«Open Tech» — це якраз і наслідок
такого, я думаю, от поштовху,
який ми створили через наш фонд «Відкриті очі»,
де ми підштовхнули креативних людей,
які можуть і хочуть щось робити.
І вони свою несистемну роботу
об'єднали в новий системний проєкт.
Це краудсорсингова програма,
де ми збираємо волонтерів,
які готові присвячувати свій час, свої вміння,
власне, робити те, що вони вміють найкраще,
для проєктів, які вони самі можуть обрати.
Ну, це проєкти некомерційні.
Це мають бути громадські організації
або державні установи.
Проєкт, за яким не стоїть якась політична складова.
Проєкт у своїй основі має
мати набагато більший вплив,
ніж просто фінанси,
які потрачені на цей проєкт.
Тому що фінанси — це ресурс,
точно такий як час,
як інтелект, як досвід.
Коли в нашій країні почалася війна
і, мені здається, майже всі офіси,
чи якісь компанії відповідальні,
чи бізнес, чи громадські організації
об’єдналися для того, щоб допомагати
хлопцям, дівчатам, які були на сході.
Тоді на «SoftServe», на коридорах
просто були зібрані якісь кошти,
там якісь бронежилети.
Наші працівники робили
безпілотники, купували машини.
Тобто будь-які запити оброблялися
в дуже швидкому темпі,
вирішувалася їхня пріоритетність,
перевірялася також правдивість.
Один з напрямів, якому ми стараємося
багато помагати, — це медицина.
І в тому напрямі ми маємо
один дуже класний проєкт.
Він називається «Кімната позитиву».
Де діти, які перебувають
у лікарні довгий період часу,
по-перше, можуть навчатися чи
гратися з елементами навчання,
а друге — кожна ця кімната,
залежно від профілю лікарні,
має свою специфіку,
де ми разом з лікарями розробили
ігрові елементи для дітей.
Коли дитина в грі, вона,
наприклад, відновлює моторику,
якщо в неї були якісь проблеми з моторикою.
Кімната позитиву — це такий
мультиплікаційний проєкт.
Ми відкрили в Рівному,
в Івано-Франківську, в Дніпрі, Харкові
і зараз плануємо у Львові, в Чернівцях і в Києві.
Також інший проєкт «IT-школяр».
Оголошуємо такий «Open Call»,
і тоді наші працівники формують команду
та вчать кілька місяців дітей,
уже випускників шкіл,
які потім можуть, якщо вони хочуть,
якщо вони запаляться, змотивуються,
вони можуть йти в технічну якусь спеціальність
і в майбутньому стати нашими колегами.
Наприклад, Богдан — студент 4-го курсу.
Він закінчував «SoftServe IT-академію».
Деякі проєкти волонтерські, власне,
на них тренуються студенти «IT-академії».
Один з них — це «Позашкілля».
І там Богдан долучився до цього проєкту.
Він завершив навчання в «ІТ-академії»,
вже працює в «SoftServе»,
але вирішив продовжити
працювати над «Позашкіллям».
Він поділився чому — це тому що колектив,
тому що дуже команда дружня зібралась там,
плюс це можливість потренувати якісь нові навички,
яких не можна потренувати на клієнтському проєкті.
Ці речі, вони зворушують, вони надихають
і вони дають оці такі щоденні ранішні крила
й ентузіазм до роботи, мотивацію.
На попередній роботі я просто відчувала, що
те, що я роблю недостатньо
для того, щоб кайфувати.
Тобто я прокидалася вранці
і не хотіла йти на роботу,
а тепер я прокидаюся вранці і така:
«О, та, сьогодні в нас великий день!».
Ми розуміємо, що за кожним нашим
кроком щодня є потужний вплив.
Що ми не просто IT-компанія,
а ми маємо потужну корпоративну
соціальну відповідальність.
Ми хочемо своїми діями через фонд
створити середовище,
де кожна людина, яка насамперед
працює в нашій компанії,
щоб вона хотіла так чи інакше долучитися
до якихось благодійних речей.
Чи, можливо, організувати якусь групу людей,
для того, щоб щось змінити чи чогось добитися.
Це передусім приклад для інших компаній.
І це дуже класно.Тут не йдеться
про якусь конкуренцію.
Хоча здорова конкуренція —
це теж дуже круто.
І якщо такі програми запускатимуться
в інших компаніях — це лише на краще.
Отже, ми будем робити якісніші речі.
Для цього потрібно більше компаній
і в ІТ, і в агро, і в торгівлі.
Щоб ще більше людей хотіло займатися
корпоративно соціальною відповідальністю,
тому що так також міняємо Україну на краще.